okay well four people joining this live
stream we are talking about various
language features as we come to the end
of the version 12 language design cycle
for language okay
first is a lovely function called subset
map um which is essentially supporting
reversible functional programming that
it's going to be useful for all kinds of
things including quantum computing and
other such areas by the way where have
we got the the current version of our
quantum computing package where is is it
a distributable package when we're gonna
put it in the function repository and
things or what's the story with it at
the moment we don't have it in master
yeah I understand well we might be able
to at least put it in the in the
function of posit Orion things the
problem is that it's not a package that
it's a collection of independent
functions they are how many other like
five or six at the moment it's about a
dozen well okay and but my worry is that
they are two interlinked to be naturally
implemented in the function repository
all right let's take a look at that map
yeah so two short questions one is if
you go to the scope area where I was
looking for examples I realized that the
third example this one working with the
even letter palindromes wondering
whether this function should do
something special for Strings
so I'm trying to understand what this is
doing um yes so it's it's it's
separating the characters of those words
and then reversing their even once to
show that you get the same thing back
yeah I understand but I mean map could
do something special for Strings - I
mean we don't have a string map we could
it turned into a list and then you do it
I think that's fine okay and the second
thing if you go to the very end
yes so I updated these two to have a
logarithmic axis on the in the number of
steps to show that the action happens
more less in the middle that's cute yeah
so they then further down in possible
issues is a comment from the yes so the
problem is that when we specify the
provision when we specify the list of
positions in an unordered way what we
get is a bit surprising I think it's
correct but I wanted to make sure that
you are giving okay
if the list of positions is not ordered
I might try to understand this it's it's
not easy
okay so your first doing okay so three
to one is a single gulp right we are
selecting positions 3 2 1 so C ba okay
so then that is fed to accumulate in
spread CBA
and outcomes that right and now we
insert to see in the third position B in
the second position a plus B plus C in
the first position we took 3 2 one out
oh and then we're inserting them back in
positions 3 2 1 that's what's gonna
happen
yeah yes I was wondering whether assort
somewhere was helpful do but I think
users should provide the position so if
that's yeah that's what they want then
they should sort them and you should
probably give that you should probably
put a you know put the second example
here which has sort in front of the 3 2
1 because what that will do presumably
what happened here
it's it's
the put system in front
perhaps it's the same problem we had
yesterday that's the case I'll switch my
maybe you can report this appears in
system and global maybe you can report
it to doesn't work ok but this has
emerged ok all right
soft and then yes knitting knitting of
this function shouldn't map thread B in
that list of see also so and do we have
back pointers here to you can you put
those in all yes I was thinking more
about the guys pages worth to put this
mm-hmm
ok let's figure that out okay so let's
go okay so we want to look for map
thread oops
won't appear ever ever that'd be nice if
we were doing if we were using our own
technology for that too searching and we
should be I should get myself a version
of this that uses our text search I'm ok
applying functions to lists
okay well let's look at several of these
um I want know your friend yes
what's the difference between block map
and a red filter
certainly black mark is very related to
subsidy yes and I think arguably should
be the first link there
I think here we want to have a section
called
I mean there's kind of a family of
multi-element okay I would argue here we
might want to say multi element
and we'd say map a function on two
blocks of elements looks okay now um oh
my gosh whoa okay and subset map map a
function in place
and now our a filter we need to know
what that does
I do not know the difference between
these um
could somebody sit and get shadi on the
phone sure
okay now where else should we yeah I
think that's the main perhaps in the
previous one together with the list this
list map thread mop mop mop no what is
this thing hold on a second so hold on
what does block map how it says block so
I think array filter is specifying what
you want back ten objects no sorry it's
doing some oh it's taking the neighbors
is blocking the block map I understand
hi we are trying to understand that this
is in block map and Ray filter
hmmm array filter appears to be a very
cellular automaton like function right
as opposed to block map which appears to
form the blocks and then map yeah if you
remember block map is just partition map
exactly it's just that it's just a
wrapper around partition yes sorry here
by the way um I think we should put in a
block map and subset map um sorry now
okay so what is a ray filter
you
it seems to be applying the elements to
the neighbors solid function to the
neighbors of a given element yes that's
right I mean I think it does it's like
an elementary you know it's like a salad
or Taunton but why is it different from
I think it's really the argument spec
array filter is doing neighborhoods the
range specification rather than the
length specification so one one defines
radius the other one the link um should
we mention or a filter here or should we
just leave this as block map on this on
this page about I think it's you
dimensions math on elements and or
neighborhoods of elements
um and I also know they said we have the
template in the Ray filter so some
subtle differences there but a sense of
the two functions are the same I feel
okay map um
apply a function to neighborhoods
to neighborhoods in an array
okay I think that's what we need you for
shadi
thank you very much all right thank you
okay
I sure hope a filter points to how could
it not point to lists convolve oh my
gosh there's so many things here that
need to be okay so this should point to
lists involved somewhere yes and a good
suggestion made our live stream ad
examples of a filter and block map to
each other's properties and Relations
sections
I completely agree so
this should have okay and right let's
convolve okay let's see this tumba
should also get a rave filter
oh my um
okay alright I think we're we're good
with this so you will do the remaining
knitting for subset map yes yep um
trying to figure this any other place we
need to insert it like Briggs arm pole
anything about in place operations I
don't think so um alright let's assume
that's that's good okay on would see use
of working precision in angle path yeah
well I strongly support that angle path
you know you just you just have a little
turtle and it goes bonkers because it's
because it takes too long I think it
should be smaller than that I mean I
think I by the time you've got a hundred
steps in an angle part okay so let's
let's look at this I mean if I say angle
path let's just say I'd say range of a
hundred okay so that's some symbolic
thing and now I would say um
graphics of line of that okay that was
fairly fast but if I go up to like
10,000 even a thousand yes that's a
noticeable delay and that's just stupid
so maybe the threshold you were
suggesting 100 yes I mean because if I
do this numerically right this will be
like blindingly well he says it's
blindingly fast but that was far
actually I had two interesting let's
find out what these two let's find out
how long they took um yeah blindingly
different right yes oh yeah I think we
should add a working precision option I
mean this is probably you know it's not
412 oh I guess okay well then let's do
it
um yes I think hundred is fine okay
so angle path has option
which determines the precision of number
of numbers generated but the default
setting exact numbers will be generated
until for only for small for short paths
well we have to save that for exact
input so it's nicely exact numbers
generated for exact input um only for
fairly short paths for longer paths
machine precision will be used okay okay
if you can trivially add this let's do
it excellent okay save the turtles right
um okay sorry yeah okay okay like
somatic theory so is axiomatic theory in
the build now aimed excellent okay let
me admire it
everything ever comes up where is it
help Sushma can you just make people
aware of this unbelievably slow startup
which I've been seeing for the last few
days no both of them okay okay so in
prototype okay so if I say axiomatic
theory do we have autocompletes yet four
things and I say group theory for
example I think it's good to see
reactions a group axioms groups yes why
is why we calling it that why was it not
group theory that's fairly swank what it
does I think I think we had a discussion
about this and I can look back through
the notes but we there were there was
because of the situation that we had
with like figuring out what it what
objects the axioms are semantically
describing I think we came to the
conclusion that group axioms made more
sense than group theory I'm particularly
given though there are several
equivalent axiomatization zuv the same
thing hey Sandra I live stream is asking
a question which I would like to check
here so he's asking what happens to I
mean so right now and in what we're
planning if you have up to a hundred
steps no problem the octagon will riri
do itself now if we if we do numerical
values here
let's numerical eyes that I don't think
there's gonna be a problem I think I
think there is event show okay this is
starting to thicken right and at a
hundred thousand steps I wonder if it'll
be thickening yeah there's some minor
thickening there well that's life in the
world of approximate numbers I don't
think there's a huge problem with this
it will it will close perfectly and you
probably should put that impossible
issues that um you know weather
thing closes perfectly and so on right
it's working position infinity this
would be right exactly
okay let's admire some axioms here okay
if you do bracket bracket you get I know
but I think that's a horrible thing okay
that's my lovely axioms um okay so what
you're asking here is should equation or
proof find equational proof of theorem
comma theory be accepted yeah definitely
why not okay
so then a follow-up question is where
you have a notable named theorem
should you be able to request for that
theorem so should you should he be able
to say you know where do we get notable
named theorems well so as a second
argument axiomatic theory you can call
notable theorems and you get back and I
think it's an association of notable
theorems and so what what is that that's
one half of the proof that the wolfram
axioms are equivalent scheffers
axiomatization but that is just the
Shaffer axiomatization isn't it right so
if you want I if you want to prove
they're equivalent you have to prove one
from the other and vice versa
right okay so for example if I look at
group axioms notable theorems but don't
forget to get the autocompletes working
these you know what is the ordering of
these notable theorems right now there
is none all right I mean this is
certainly not the most important notable
theorem of group theory let's make some
minor effort to order them in a sensible
way sure
like here we could start with
Nativity and so on yeah maybe simplest I
mean like short us to write down the
theorems should go first or something
that there's probably an easy way to do
it yeah yeah but I think these ones that
are there are the connections to other
theorems seem yeah I think so yeah
because that's matter that's
metamathematics effectively rather than
I mean let's boot math before metamath
right that's a clear good adage um okay
those are alphabetical order right yes
so the question is should he be able to
call something like find equational
proof wolfram axioms , commutativity no
but you've got that the wrong way around
unless we change find equational proof
which were which we already cooked the
goose song right of when is this raft
going to be fixed it's still looking
wrong could you please ping that again
yes
no I I mean as a as a list in the first
argument that you you say you have a
list where the first item is you know
the theory and the second item is the
theorem and then you pass the axioms as
in second arguments of fine equational
proof as normal what what why is there a
theory in the first argument I
understand that
um okay by the way did did find
equational proof end up with it the nice
new centrality based appearance uh yeah
oh no oh it has half of it it has the
logistic sigmoid rescaling that we added
but I'm not sure whether it has the
betweenness centrality weightings I can
add that if not okay so let's take a
look here um so if we find equational
proof of okay I just want to actually
see what this feels like so that then
then what you've got there is that okay
and so what you have here would be
notable theorems and then I would say
commutativity is that correct right and
you're proposing okay so this will now
grind away hopefully hey what's the
stages of the memory leak as Marcus
replied how could okay come on we can
find him
there's some issue here there's some
problem come on that doesn't make sense
it's not really a memory leak we found
it's it is just this math link but then
he's not probably the expert person so
it's okay no the shoddy and ask her what
you know maybe he just does not replying
because he has nothing to say
in which case that's really bad because
it should go to somebody else what am I
doing here proof graph proof growth okay
that's still the old one yep I suppose a
was mentioning that and the nose looked
too small I now realize why that's the
case I had yeah in the in the new graph
rendering I have the logistic sigmoid
rescaling but not the betweenness
centrality rescaling whereas it really
makes sense to have both so I'll modify
that okay well so oh is that the only
form that we're giving through the proof
network is the one with the betweenness
centrality we could offer both how I
don't know proof proof graph and proof
graph weighted or something
I don't know which should be the default
problem neither is a default I think the
weight it should be in which case what
we call unweighted proof graph is the
other
um
well I don't know whether it should be
the default
I think we should have it as a
non-default I think it should be
weighted proof graph is the thing that
if you're in the know you use or Braille
showed a big proof weighted graph
weighted no weighted proof graph is fine
um and there's no default right so I
mean there's nothing there's no default
at all so now you've changed the the
documentation here so that it
it prolly should be called proof graph
weighted if it's going to do that
by the way somebody on our livestream is
saying that percent needs an overhaul I
100% agree we have a beautiful design
that we're just waiting for time to
implement
thank you for supporting that idea that
percent needs an overhaul because I've
been pushing that for several years
um let's call it if we can hear um
proof weighted graph does that make
sense or proof graph weighted which do
you think is better proof graph weighted
sounds more natural to me at least okay
you
I'm emphasized with central lemmas
emphasized
you
um okay can you implement that easily
yep that's no problem okay
you
you
should we flip around the
volts no I don't think so I think it's
more honest to just just give this I
mean the other one is interesting but I
think this is the more direct version
right okay and this looks a bit small to
me oh yeah I mean it's gotta be gotten
right what we had before was right
this is the this is using the sigmoid
model that we designed
right but the sigmoid model should not
be in a engaged unless there's a
betweenness centrality wait okay I you
so for the for the default like just
unweighted proof graph you want to use
exactly what were using before I think
so I think we optimized it well okay
yeah I yeah I'll modify that okay um
okay so find equation or proof okay this
obviously should talk about me haven't
even started talking about that it
should point to axiomatic theory is
there a documentation page there is not
and in fact I wants to ask how involved
do you want to be in the documentation
for axiomatic theory I want to look at
it and I mean do we do we think yeah so
the answer to your question is we
absolutely should have it be the case
that I mean should we should we make a
bit of beginning of a page for axiomatic
theory yeah but you know I mean the for
me at least the key thing is to nail
down what how should what is the correct
design for this notable theorem stuff or
I mean should we support that at all
where you can just prove names theorems
directly in fine equational proof so
your proposal would be that you should
be able to say just commutativity there
yeah i'm this is the thing i'm not sure
whether it should be a little whether it
should be a list of Wolfram axioms comma
commutativity or rather be in plus no I
think it should be implicit if what you
say is this if if what you've got is not
that but this
right I mean that might as well work
right so that means they come in a DVT
theorem that is correct it means exactly
what I wrote up here and if it isn't a
notable theorem then it should error out
saying that wasn't a notable theorem of
that axiom system right I think it's
pretty neat that we've got these axioms
as as kind of from yeah anyway okay so
what we're gonna have to do for now
unfortunately is some we're just gonna
have to make a table of all of those
seventeen axiom systems makes sense as
documentation yeah yeah in the
documentation
I mean it's unfortunate but I think
that's what we should do okay
I mean what about in the future if we
have you know hundreds of these things
well obviously what we're going to go to
is something directly analogous to what
we've gone through for interpreters and
other things special documentation pages
for axiom systems okay will be a
category of documentation page for axiom
systems just like we have ones you know
import output formats and etc etcetera
etcetera okay so this means that in here
let's see um I think just to help people
out here we should do this we should say
find equational proof their own common
name users tries to find a proof of THM
using the named axiomatic theory
you
specified name
magic theory
um and then we probably want to say down
below um
Oh mass mass mass so find equational
proof of THM common name is equivalent
to theory
okay it's equivalent to find equational
proof of theorem comma axiomatic theory
of quotes theory okay and then we can
also add another line that says find
equation or proof tries to find a proof
of the named notable theorem
from Maxim attic theory theory , notable
the theorems
you
okay
should-should that possibility be
detailed at the top or I don't think so
okay think by the term we've got this
and we can give this in some examples as
well sure
yeah and so here you can exactly know
now we can change this right right okay
question about which their improve is
being used so this is primarily a
equational logic theorem protocol bull
meister the we are working extensively
on things with lean and some other
theorem provers and in terms of
interactive proof assistance ii up
there's interesting things coming in
that direction um could machine learning
be used to make the proved of more
intelligent yep we are looking at that
um although frankly it's pretty good
right now really quite quite good quite
impressive i mean certainly you know all
i can say is that years ago with this
technology stack i prove theorems that
had people have been trying to prove for
like 20-something years pretty easily so
it's certainly beyond human performance
and in many respects alright let's
document axiomatic theory a little bit
here okay um so okay axiomatic theory of
theory um now what should it say gives a
representation so if I say axiomatic
theory of group axioms and so here we
should say where's the example if I
don't usually do this part of things so
um insert text right
give this standards give a statement of
this standard axioms for group theory
okay so here alright so I don't know how
much we're not gonna have winner run out
of time on this so I mean I think let me
just are we making this experimental or
not I guess we should everything else in
this Eric general area is experimental I
think so yeah it really should be okay
gives a representation of the axiomatic
of the named gives a representation of
the specified named axiomatic theory the
axiomatic theory with the specified name
well no I'm actually met of the
axiomatic theory okay so that's the most
basic thing gives an axiomatic
representation gives is that a
reasonable way to say it I mean so what
we're gonna want to say here is
axiomatic theory by default users now
what is it using for the variables users
normal symbols and what happened to the
function that generates formal symbols
do we have that now that formal symbol
function did we ever did we got do we
implement that in the end not yet okay
by default uses formal symbols such as
formal a to represent variables that
right um
axiomatic theory by default uses
operators such as circle x and Center
dot should we specify that these
operators without predefined meanings
yeah
without predefined values such as by
default uses operators without
predefined meanings such as without
predefined values such as the bar thank
you to represent operators how to
represent operators in the theory to
represent variables in represent
essentially local variables in axioms
what should we call them to represent
scoped variables
they're not scoped what are they called
in formal logic I mean free variables is
what they are essentially let's call
them that by default users
cymbals I think we should say um such as
circle times and center dot uses
functions without predefined values but
with this functions with predefined
formatting but without predefined values
to represent operators in axioms
examples are circle x and circle dot
formatted as oh it's a pity that's a
period period thing okay so now what's
the next thing we want to say here so um
the axiomatic theory supports theories
including and let me just write out a
few and I think here what we should do
is try and write it from the which is
the biggest axioms here what are the
arithmetic axioms do they look like
they're not particularly big I suspect
field axioms of the largest well I mean
the question is representing the largest
why are they so small that's not pure
isn't it there's no there's no
introduction right we mean it's not
meant to be piano arithmetic we don't
have we never came up with a design for
representing axiom schema so we can't
why are we calling this arithmetic
axioms
they're axioms in which you can prove
simple theorems of arithmetic why don't
we call them addition axioms since that
work that's what they seem to be about
we can do that I think it's what we
should do um because people will look
for pianura arithmetic here and they
will be disappointed if they don't find
it which they won't yet because I mean
did when we have an axiom schema what
will we be able to use it for until we
have a different family of proves I hope
that we'll be able to use it will we
presumably not I mean there are
presumably certain restrictions you
could make if you know you specify
finite models or something where you can
make sense of axiom schemas using first
order theorem provers okay so that the
next case we have here is comma properly
right right
gives the specified property Almanac
semantic theory I think it's cool that
it's inconceivable to represent all
these things here axiomatic Theory
supports okay so now and then how do you
give how do you specify the the settings
for the so that's passed as a list in
the first argument so you give a list
where the first element is the theory
name and the second element is an
association of operators okay so we
should we should change that um okay and
the free variables you don't get to to
redefine is that correct that is correct
yep okay so this is up one Operator one
goes to what should we call it sim 1s
one let's say
users a representation uses s sub I to
represent the operator named op sub I in
the theory
question from our livestream is this
related to category theory hmm
interesting question saunders MacLean
always used to like to claim that
category theory is not an axiomatic
theory but actually it has axioms like
everything else but I don't think we
have the axioms of category theory don't
didn't I have them in the NTS book the
axioms of category theory yeah you did
but they're non equational so when we
have when we have fine predicate proof
we can in fact like there was one of the
test cases I ran it almost the
elementary category theory axioms from
the book but because that's not in 12
it's not an axiomatic theory but so what
is the so axiomatic theory eventually
will also support what do you mean it's
not an axiomatic what what what is the
characteristic does it have an axiom
schema or does it have something else in
it no no it's it has its finitely axiom
it I support but it uses it's not
conventionally written in equation or
logic it's written in full first-order
logic
I see much like say presberg arithmetic
which we will also be able to support
but we don't yet when we have fried
Broker proof yes okay that will be very
interesting so we can't we can do some
category theory there improving but it
just won't be in 12 right how is it
going with the predicate thing but find
predicate proof well we need to have a
Jose and I need to talk more about it by
I obviously I haven't been working on it
very much but the the foundation is
there like it works it's it's mostly
design stuff now I think okay supports
the following properties standard
properties properties what are they you
can do actual antique theory properties
operator rules has been changed to
operator apologies okay
okay list of axioms list of axioms um
should we say something about state and
first-order logic or we don't just say
that an imperfect problem no we don't
just say that I'll change this should
link to entity pages by the way that's
the thing that's what sushma that's a
general thing we need to do is is now
that we have entity pages we need to
think about how we link from functions
to entity pages okay that may need a
discussion with the documentation team
you
now just list of axioms okay what's the
next thing you think should we list
operators what is operators
operators used in the axioms names of
operators used in the axioms well it's
it's names and symbols what does it look
like it get it gives back a list of or
an association actually I think of
operators and their and their symbols
so same multiplication arrow circle
docile whatever
operators and their representations or
their
default representation is it default no
because if you override it and then call
operators you get back the new
representation okay so the next one is
operator era T's
and the next one was that operated
groupings is that right are we calling
it okay okay okay
so that's suitable for use in grouping
yes exactly
um operator era tees gives a list
suitable
that's gonna be a nice feature in that
they're worthwhile examples to be given
about that okay
notable theorems association of notable
theorems
well notable named theorems in the
theory my name we don't have to
well notable named theorems in the
theory okay and now I think I can leave
you guys to do this what we're going to
call it sub theories okay equivalent
theories there is equivalent to this one
names of theories equivalent to this one
there is that are named theories that
our subsets of this one is that right
yeah sort of that can be proved from
this one right although that I mean
that's not a that's not quite right
because if the theory is equivalent it
can also be proved nothing a theory so
theories that are that contain this one
that are contained by this one right yep
I think that's the right yes that's the
right way all right
um axiomatic theory supports there is
including and I'm not going to fill them
all in right now but let me just fill in
one
group theory with standard axioms could
be the start there I don't know what
order we should it is in any thoughts
perhaps what happened to my other axioms
the essence with commutativity they are
not in there yes by the way you should
say axiom it's just one axiom
interesting all right okay okay okay
well fine
what kinds of things for things like the
mccune axioms of group theory there's I
mean technically the way we've
represented it is just as a single axiom
but that conventionally referred to as
the mccune axioms all right fine
all right so um what are we gonna call
that other axiom I find the one with
commutativity abelian wolfram axioms now
I can go commutative it's not a billion
because it's not gonna be in theory yeah
that was a joke commute support from
axioms it doesn't seem unreasonable okay
um there are also alternative forms of
my axioms which are kind of interesting
which are in the end KS book we might as
well have them since we since they're
available so to speak right I just I
don't remember how many there are there
there is one in equivalent there are
several in equivalent ones um I can get
PK the summer camp student to come
through and add these things that will
be wonderful is he gonna add lattice
theory and things like that also I I
don't know I mean there's lattice theory
in
outs in the uncurse book yep okay um
let's get that III was I focused just on
getting all of the other ones from the
main text but yes there are other things
in the notes that are eventually look
there we go there's an alternate form
okay so there's that one which is the
commutative one what is that one there
is that David Hillman's one is that
something yet different oh no II is the
Meredith axiom system so let's please
get that sure okay so then we're having
listen just make a note here so they'll
end up being Meredith axioms they'll end
up being and probably alternate both
Maxim's which is that lost it's a little
bit annoying that that comes that the
ordering is that let's do this let's say
well from commutative axioms well from
alternate axioms and then let's please
I'm pretty sure the notes okay somebody
on the live stream is asking would you
be able to know if you have the shortest
proof good friggin luck no it's in
general undecidable um we do our best
that's why we use the word try and find
equational proof be super impressed you
can get any proof at all I'm right there
are speed-up theorems and things which
which show that it's undecidable in
general indeed the okay so fine all
right let's get a draft with this page
if we can and then we'll go through that
and
yeah this is lovely thing as always
thing um cool do you think PK could also
get some notable theorems some other
notable theorems for some of these
things yeah probably I mean these were
just things that I could think of I mean
there was no I had no particularly
systematic process for producing these
things presumably he can think of more
and as a QA matter you did try it you
did prove all the notable theorems from
those theories yeah yeah they're all
they're all decidable it's okay
no I understand um what I'm saying there
is is um you know those are good test
cases to use I mean they should be in
the test Suites probably right um yeah
let's try and collect some more of these
things um and it's remarkable that
mathematics can be compressed into this
sum you know I I i mean the other
question is for groups for example is
there a way of getting I mean
specializing to a particular group I
mean that's that's where we get into
model theoretic stuff we still haven't
completely worked out how that should
work in the context of like fine
countering we're finding counter
examples and things right but what is
that one Kilda thingy that was the you
suggested that is the identity element
okay all right so constants axiomatic
theory by default uses functions
let's say to represent operators and
constants in axioms like leave it to you
to figure out what we do with this and
well I don't know how we do that here
what would we say just the tilde for the
over tilde I think we just do this
except there isn't another tilde so I'm
confused
perhaps there's nothing perhaps you can
have one of these this square
representing something to be inserted oh
yeah place over a placeholder and we put
under it
okay all right I'll leave this to you to
do now have we failed to get shoot I
have to go to a different meeting here
before oh I really gotta go to this one
um let me see what do we fail to do here
we haven't talked about
oh gosh you've got the the I really
gotta go to this gym for tomorrow hmm I
need more examples you have to say how
it's displayed and also don't we have a
isn't there an infix isn't there a way
to enter the thing but if I stay around
X I don't know why doesn't okay okay
look Jose if you if you want to go over
this with me if you're available
sometime this evening we could go over
this in more detail if you think it's
useful okay um all right sounds good
okay thank you Jonathan um and everybody
else here
Oh question for the live stream those
are always fun kind of chess game like
chess be included as a proof theory
problem actually somebody did a really
nice project about related things at the
summer school this year you can look it
up um and um yeah okay good stuff all
right thank you all I will push these
changes back yeah thanks okay see ya
okay bye